it's time that we take the barrier down
forever
you know we love you mal and we are so
glad that you deliver your happily ever
after with Ben you guys make the cutest
couple ever you have been through a lot
and come out stronger for it and you
will be the best king and queen our dine
has ever seen but we have to admit there
are some things about your relationship
that have us scratching our heads some
vans love mal and Ben but there are
definitely critics we take a look at all
the secrets and truths in this royal
descendants relationship keep watching
to find out why now and then are perfect
for each other
the ex problem usually when
relationships ends you never have to see
your ex again or at least you don't have
to hang out too closely with them but
mal and vent don't have that luxury
let's take a look at Ben's ex Audrey
obviously caused some major problems in
descendants 3 she was mostly upset that
she wasn't going to become the queen of
auradon yes but she also still had
serious feelings for Ben she even tried
to get him back before she turned him
into a beast
she still has pictures of them as a
couple all over her room Ben grew up
expecting to marry Audrey in Audrey's
room there is a picture of the two of
them as really young kids they have been
together for a long time but where did
all of Ben's feelings for Rodrigo he
tells her in the third movie that he
likes the old Audrey better he was
worried that someone had cast a spell on
her and was willing to do it ever to
stay 4 from it Audrey may have realized
that mal isn't evil but she is still
very much a part of life in auradon this
probably causes some serious issues
between Ben and mal it's hard to deal
with your fiancé's ex things are
probably going to continue to be really
awkward with Audrey for a while now that
the barrier to the Isle of the Lost has
been destroyed
mal has a past of her own to deal with
in real life dub Cameron is dating
Thomas Doherty who plays Harry hook and
they are an adorable couple lots of fans
wish mal had ended up with Harry because
they have such great chemistry it's not
addressed in the movies but Dov and
Thomas created their own fan theory they
believe that mal and Harry used to date
on the Isle and Harry is definitely into
her in descendants 3 we love this theory
Harry can be a huge flirt and he can
also be pretty mean but since mal and
uma are friends again
and Harry is close with uma these
two exes will be seeing each other a lot
Harry seems like the type of guy who
would totally rub in his past with Mal
to make Ben Jealous we just hope that
Harry hits it off with a dream so the
two exes won't be that much of a problem
opposites attract
mal and Ben are two completely different
people now grew up on the Isle she was
poor and raised by a really terrible
mother she didn't have a relationship
with her father ontology Sinan's 3 then
grew up as a prince
his parents are supportive and they have
a great relationship mal is tough she's
a fighter literally she knows how to
fight and is your crazy defend herself
or the people she cares about Ben is a
diplomat he always wants to talk things
out first but these two have some very
important things in common they are both
extremely loyal and protective and they
both care about important things like
the kids on the Isle Ben is definitely
in the minority when he decides to open
the barrier in the first movie and now
really wants her people to be free they
definitely have true love now breaks the
spell uma cast-on been in descendants
too with true love's kiss more for me I
guess those on lines as strong as their
relationship is it didn't start under
the healthiest circumstances fans are
quick to point out that mal can be
really manipulative she gave Ben a love
potion in the first movie to try to
achieve her mother's plan she fell in
love with him when she realized how
great he was but she believed him to be
under the love spell people don't
realize that then totally played now to
the love spell washed off on their first
date but he let her think he was still
under the spell they both fell in love
by lying to each other let's give the
anti-love potion a few minutes to take
effect
they also aren't the best at
communicating now hide really hard to
make been happy in descendants - but she
didn't tell him how she really felt then
didn't tell her that the cotillion is
essentially an engagement party
thankfully by dissonance theory these
two have stopped lying to each other
growing up
Mao and Ben are really young they are
just now finishing high school
can you imagine ruling a country as a
teenager they have grown up a lot since
the first movie but they still have a
lot more growing up to do they have to
learn how to rule together at the end of
the sentence three now announces the
barrier coming down forever without even
asking then and it's time that we taped
the barrier down forever that also needs
to get better at understanding mal she
gets embarrassed with his big public
gestures of love but we know these two
can handle anything it's true love after
all do you think Malin Ben belong
together or would they be better off
with someone else
sound off in the comments the truth
about mal and Ben's relationship in
descendants 3 thank you for watching
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to click Subscribe we'll
see you next time
[Music]